اليوم البرلمان الاوروبي اذان الجزائر
كانوا يدينوا اسرائيل اللي تقتل في
الفلسطينيين ناس مجردين
ابرياء
يوميا يوميا الموت يوميا الموت
والاتحاد الاوروبي تحرك تحرك ولو بكلمه
المغرب يجمع دول الغرب على اراضيه وبعد ان
وصلت اسرائيل الى الحدود الجزائريه بوتين
يستدعي تبون على الفور تعال يا صديقي
فلدينا امور هامه لمناقشتها مناوره عسكريه
عنيفه في افريقيا تحرك المياه الراكده
وتشعل الاجواء المغرب والولايات المتحده
واسرائيل نعم اسرائيل مع مجموعه من دول
الغرب يتحضرون للحرب واين بالقرب من
الجزائر فما الذي يفعله الجيش الاسرائيلي
في المغرب وعلى حدوده مع الجزائر اليكم
الاجابه
طائيل والاسد الافريقي
هي المره الاولى في تاريخه الكيان
الاسرائيلي يتدرب على الاراضي المغربيه
يالا غرابه الموقف اعداء الامس اصدقاء
اليوم ويتدربون معا او هكذا يقولوه الواقع
لتشرح المناورات ما تبقى من التفاصيل اضخم
مناورات عسكريه في القاره السمراء اقيمت
بالمغرب البلد العربي الذي ينظم هذه
المناورات مع الولايات المتحده سنويا
وبصوره مشتركه وها نحن في نسختها 19 في
يونيو لعامين الجاري في الاسد الافريقي
حيث يشارك ما يقارب من ثمانيه الاف عسكري
واربعه الاف من عناصر الجيش الامريكي الى
جانب اكثر من 4000 جندي اخر من 18 دوله
تشمل المغرب تونس السنغال غانا المملكه
المتحده والبرازيل كندا وهولندا ودول اخرى
تنتمي لحلف شمال الاطلسي قبل اندلاع
المناورات التي انتهت في السادس عشر من
يونيو السلطات المغربيه مشاركه وفود
عسكريه من بلدان عده والى هنا يظل الامر
روتينيا وطبيعيا فلا جديد اعلان المغرب
نسي شيئا واحدا فقط هو لم يذكر مشاركه
اسرائيل والتي يعتبرها العرب عدوهم
التاريخي ربما ارادوا ان تبقى مفاجاه واي
مفاجاه عندما يسرح العدو ويمرح على ارضك
نعم على الارض المغربيه وخصوصا في سبع
مناطقا بالمغرب هي اكادير وطنطان والمحبس
وتزنيت والقنيطره وبنجرير وتفنيت وبالقرب
من الحدود الجزائريه حطت قوات من الجيش
الاسرائيلي رحالها بجانب قوات الدول
المشاركه الاخرى لاجراء تدريبات تكتيكيه
بريه وبحريه وجويه مشتركه ليلا ونهارا
وتمرينا مشتركا للقوات الخاصه والعمليات
المحموله جوا بالاضافه الى تمارين مكافحه
اسلحه الدمار الشامل لتشمل ايضا مراقبه
حقوق الانسان الصحراء الغربيه ومخيمات
تندوف ليس ذلك وحسب فبجانب تطوير مهارات
الميدانيه والقتاليه للقوات المشاركه هناك
سبب اخر للمناورات وهو التدريب على تضاريس
المتنوعه منها صحراء وهضاب ووديان
ومنبسطات ومناطق قريبه من البحر كما هي
تضاريس مجموع منطقه الصحراء الكبرى
وغالبيه الدول العربيه لكن ما الذي يدعو
للغرابه هذه المره اولم تشارك اسرائيل من
قبل في هذه المناوره بلى سبق للجيش
الاسرائيلي ان شارك في مناورات الاسد
الافريقي وليس ذلك ببعيد بل في العام
الماضي ولكن على مستوى مراقبين عسكريين
الدوليين فقط اي من دون اي مشاركه لجنوده
على الارض المغربيه وعلى الرغم من
التحركات الشعبيه المؤيده للفلسطينيين قد
ضعفت بعض الشيء في المغرب
التعاطف الشعبيه مع القضيه الفلسطينيه لا
يزال واسعا بينما يعمل المغرب واسرائيل
على تسريع تعونهما على جميع الاصعده منذ
تطبيع العلاقات بينهما ديسمبر عام 2020 في
اطار الاتفاقيه الابراهيميه التي توسطت
فيها الولايات المتحده واثمرت تطبيعا
للعلاقات بين الدوله العبريه وعدد من
الدول العربيه كل ما يجري من تطبيع
للعلاقات مع اسرائيل له مقابل وهنا حصل
المغرب على اعتراف بالسياده المغربيه على
الصحراء الغربيه المتنازع عليها مع جبهه
البوليساريو المدعومه من الجزائر
التطبيع مع اسرائيل مقابل الصحراء اتفاق
مغربي مع اداره الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب ورغم ان اداره بيدن تبدو غير
متحمسه للاتفاق وتتجنب غضب الجزائر ولكن
لم تغير القرار الخاص بالاعتراف بمغربيه
الصحراء على الاقل حتى اليوم اسرائيل
حاولت بشتى الطرق الانضمام للاسد الافريقي
وها هي قد حصلت على ما تتمناه فمن خلالها
هذه المناورات تسعه الابيب لتشجيع باقي
الدول العربيه على مسار التطبيق
ابناء عبد المجيد تبون لا يلعبون
مناورات الاسد الافريقي هذا العام لفتت
انظار الجزائريين قبل غيرهم وذلك لمشاركه
جنود من الجيش الاسرائيلي فيها الولايات
المتحده تنبات بالقلق الجزائري وحاولت
طمانه الجزائر بان هذه المناورات التي تعد
الاضخم في افريقيا ليست موجهه لها لكن هذه
المبررات غير مقنعه للجزائريين فبجانب
التوترات مع الشقيقه المغربيه هناك مشاركه
من العدو الاسرائيلي للجزائر ليحين وقت
التفكير بالرد وعلى حين غرارنا الهاتف
الجزائري باتصال من الرئيس بوتين الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون يجيب واذ ببوتين
يتحدث ادعوك يا صديقي لتاتي الى موسكو
وبما ان اسرائيل اقتربت من حدود الجزائر
ها هو الرئيس تبون يصل روسيا مؤتمر صحفي
للرئيسين تلاهوا عناق حار بعد انتهاء تبون
من كلمته شاهدوا كيف توجه الرئيس الروسي
بوتين مباشره نحوه ليصافحه بشده
والابتسامه تعترم ملامحهما انهما يخططان
لشيء ما هناك شيء يطبخ على نار هادئه حيث
كان الجيش الجزائري قد استبق مناورات
الاسد الافريقي باطلاق مناورات جديده
باستخدام مختلف الاسلحه قصيره ومتوسطه
المدى مع استعمال الذخيره الحيه تحديدا
بالمنطقه العسكريه الثالثه والقطاع
العملياتي الجنوبي المعروفين بوجودهما
ببشار وتندوف المتاخمتين للحدود المغربيه
الشرقيه وحدود الصحراء وذلك قبل 11 يوما
على انطلاق مناورات الاسد الافريقي مع
انتشار هائل غير مسبوق على الحدود مع
القوات الجزائريه وهذه ليست المره الاولى
التي تحشد فيها الجزائر قواتها على الحدود
الشرقيه فقد نفذت سابقا مناوره عسكريه
مشتركه مع الحليف الروسي المسماه بدرع
الصحراء في قاعده حماقي جنوب غربي البلاد
لمحاكاه القتال السابق لما يسمى بحرب
الرمال بين الجزائر والمغرب وقع الرئيسان
بوتين وتابون اعلان الشراكه العميقه بين
البلدين مع محادثات بينهما تم وصفها
بالمثمره ليناقش الجانبان القضايا ذات
الاهتمام المشترك في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا واما الهدف المغير هذه
المره فهو ايجاد مجالات اخرى للتعاون
بعيدا عن مجال التعاون العسكري الذي اصبح
في مامن بين البلدين ليحين وقت مجالات
اخرى كالاقتصاد والطاقه والرد على الحملات
الغربيه لتكون اولى خطوات الجزائر اعلان
الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون ان بلاده
تريد التسريع في الدخول بمجموعه بريكس ومن
ينضم لبريكس لا يستخدم الدولار كعمله
تجاريه مره اخرى وهنا تقول الجزائر باي
باي للدولار الامريكي وكذلك لليورو
الاوروبي وهي ضربه للولايات المتحده
بالدرجه الاولى وللدول الاوروبيه من بعدها
فما هو التالي يا ابناء تبون النظام
الجزائري يمضي في رده على التقارب المغربي
مع الحلفاء الغربيين وخصوصا مع الكيان
الاسرائيلي وهل هناك ما هو افضل من
التحالف مع روسيا
[تصفيق]